[Music]
now i can't emphasize enough
how important all this playful is both
for developing good posture habits
and for moving us towards really fun
stuff with poi
for instance
if you want to be able to learn to do
this boy
it's really good to start with the arms
which is what we're going to do right
now
so face this way with me pow and again
for me i've got my float and my tree
so we're going to turn this way together
you've got whatever and this is going to
help you stay consistent
so i'm looking at my float and i'm
swimming forwards
do this with me like you're doing a
front crawl
right you're swimming towards whatever's
over there
okay now notice that
every time you get the right arm
forwards you're kind of standing in this
position
awesome that's we'll call that neutral
arms are open
so my right hand's pointing at my float
my left hand is putting up my tree
so from here if i look over there as my
right hand is going down
i swim forwards towards my float
when i get back to there i'm back where
i started if i look at my tree
that hand's going up so look at my tree
i'm going to swim backwards
away from the tree until i get back to
where i started
okay you can keep relaxing keep
breathing and relaxing
so from here i look at my float i can do
a circle towards my float
i can look at my tree and do a circle
away from the tree
and my whole body's turning everything
is relaxed i really
turn to do the circle circle towards the
float
circle backward away from the tree
forwards towards the float
backwards away from the tree and with
practice
it'll become this away from the tree
towards the float
away from the tree towards float check
it out
now your arms might get tired and your
brain might get kind of confused
so you can come back to this a couple
times before it starts to work
and you'll know it's working when you go
boom boom
down on this side up on this side you
think you look this way and see when i
look that way it naturally turns my body
a bit
forward circle backward circle
forward circle and at first you can take
as much time as you want
okay that's up so backwards away from
the tree
forwards and eventually you'll just roll
through it
and it can come smaller or really big
and what you want to make sure is that
your posture is good you're standing
tall
and it feels good you want your body
turning enough that you're not torquing
on your shoulders
if i'm turning enough look at my
shoulder if i turn enough
it's relaxed if i don't turn enough i'm
really tweaking out my shoulders so
go slow and learn the technique
of turning like i'm really pivoting on
my feet
and that's what's going to protect me
but i'm letting my whole body turn when
it works you can switch and do it the
other way you can switch and say okay
now it's gonna be down
forwards towards the tree and backwards
away from the float
forwards towards the tree backwards away
from the float
and don't be don't be afraid of letting
this take a few days
i mean if you're new at this your
shoulders might get tired really quickly
your brain might get tied in a knot
really quickly that's fine
just come back to it every day you know
when you're about to play poi warm up a
bit
do this for a couple minutes and before
you know it it's going to be
as natural as pie
speaking of which i'm gonna get some pie